two weeks ago i was at the revolt summit
which is a summit for primarily just
black people i think
a lot of celebrities there rick ross was
there
p diddy is there he runs the
organization and i was on the panel as a
black police officer and literally
everything i said to support the
relationship between law enforcement and
in the black community i got booed
um so
that that sentiment is the reason why i
think you know kind of drew me to
writing this book and wanting to express
this is another side of it that people
may not understand is that this is what
it's like actually being a black man in
america on the police department
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former police officer and now author of
the new book beaten black and blue being
a black cop in an america under siege
brandon tatum my friend welcome back to
the reuben report
what's going on dave
i'm doing all right as i said to you
right before we started just trying to
survive the revolution
and you
oh doing the same thing you know we
we're both in this together and i'm sure
we're both uh trying to make a
conservative effort to do something
about what's going on and keep a
positive attitude so i think we're on
the same page man
indeed we are that very much about
keeping a positive attitude and kind of
knowing what you're saying all that that
is sort of what the book is about we'll
obviously get to that i know most of my
audience is familiar with you already
you've been on the show a couple times
but for those that aren't can we just do
a quick recap of the the bio of brandon
tatum what made you a guy that's writing
a book about policing and and doing
crazy youtube shows like this
yeah you know the funny thing is man i
grew up in fort worth texas uh a young
man with parents were divorced and all
that other stuff and you know some
people may think that i would have
fallen down a particular path but i
believe that god had a plan for me in
college i played football
i was leaning more left
i got saved in 2008 and i never in my
life thought about being a police
officer i knew i was going to play in
the nfl i did not get drafted in 2010
although i was in the draft and it
really changed my life i became a police
officer after doing a ride-along and my
political views changed my worldview
changed in a significant way and i was a
police officer for six and a half years
i did the swat team i was a field
training officer i was a spokesperson i
did almost everything that i could on
the police department and really during
the barack obama's era it's where things
begin to really change significantly for
me and with the attacks on police during
that period of time and and the rhetoric
coming from the white house this book
idea came to my mind man i said you know
what i feel like i'm getting beat up
from both directions i'm getting beat up
as a black man trying to be a police
officer by the black community and then
i'm getting beaten up for wearing a
uniform in general by the population
that have been swindled by the
propaganda from from the mainstream
media and these political leaders and i
said one day i'm gonna write a book and
and i wrote the book last year and
leading into this year i've made some
additions to it because of the george
floyd situation however it's going to be
published november 30th and i'm excited
about it so there's obviously a ton to
talk about there related to when things
changed with policing and how it changed
but you mentioned sort of getting it
from both sides and we've talked about
that a little bit before but can you
just go into that a bit more how going
into these black communities as a black
man in some ways you told me last time
it kind of helped at times because it
gave you a little cred but then in
another way it was sort of like you were
seen as like a traitor or something like
that
yeah 100 you know some things some
people they were reasonable rational
individuals um sometimes they felt the
connection with me because i look like
them you know and maybe i sound like
them because i got kind of a country
accent it kind of going it's kind of
gone away now but at the time you know i
was a lot more country and so people
maybe identified with me and i was able
to communicate with individuals that
some officers couldn't um
more so than not people would criticize
me because i'm black and and are you
working for the white man and you're a
traitor to your people
and you know even when they would spew
rhetoric because this the white man
system of systemic racism it's like look
i'm a part i'm a part of this system and
you are proclaiming that i'm a problem
and that i'm involved in systemic racism
um and even just last week i was uh two
weeks ago i was at the revolt summit
which is a summit for primarily just
black people i think uh a lot of
celebrities that rick ross was there
uh p diddy is there he runs the
organization and i was on the panel as a
black police officer and literally
everything i said to support the
relationship between law enforcement and
the black community i got booed um so
that that sentiment is the reason why i
think you know kind of drew me to
writing this book and wanting to express
this is another side of it that people
may not understand is that this is what
it's like actually being a black man in
america on the police department did i
did i see a clip of that from revolt did
you post a clip of that getting booed or
am i thinking
i think i might be thinking of something
that was it was not that
they may have posted uh tater report may
have posted that i had attended there
but you know what the funny thing is
they scrapped when they posted this live
because it was pre-recorded they
scrapped everything me and that other
black officer said wow and we said a lot
of profound things that i think could be
invaluable to the community and they
deleted it when they posted it which is
it's shameful so what do you make of
that i mean you were invited it's not as
if they don't know what you think right
like it's not that you're gonna suddenly
get there and they're like holy cow this
guy
uh you know doesn't fall in line with us
exactly they know that to begin with
what do you make of even being invited
and then were you able to get across any
of the ideas to some of the people that
maybe were booing you
nah i mean there were people there that
already agreed kind of with the
sentiment of the police officers that
were there all the black cops that were
there supporting the event um some
people already agree but the others you
know they had their mind fixed and you
can see that it's a rigged situation
where you have uh you know them having
other voices to express the totality of
the black experience and then when it
when the push come to shove when the
audience is bigger than 50 people when
it's going out to the millions of people
that follow the revolt uh network they
completely silence your voice and the
crazy thing is is that they allow the
misrepresentation of police officers and
hateful divisive rhetoric or divisive
rhetoric they allowed those uh panelists
to have a highlighted voice and then he
deleted everybody else that said
anything different so to me it speaks to
the bigger overarching issue that
there's a
uh
effort and a push in order to block any
uh thought that's different than the
mainstream idea they want to push right
so you mentioned okay the the way the
black community sometimes felt when
you'd go into these neighborhoods and
then you mentioned the other side that
you were getting it from both sides
you're sort of describing that already
but what was that like as a police
officer you're saying okay i'm going in
to do my job but now here's the people
on the outside who are also hitting you
for it
yeah and one thing that i learned before
i became a police officer that i had no
idea what police officers actually did
and then when i became a police i was
like oh my god man we do stuff that
people have no idea about i mean we're
put in situations the things that we see
the stress that we are under the
decisions that we have to make in a
split second when uh you know you take
it to trial and attorneys have months
years to deliberate and figure out a
strategy to argue your you know half a
second decision um but we would get
pushback you know with the george floyd
not the george floyd because i wasn't a
cop during that time but michael brown
and some of these other
incidents people just projected
negativity on you you had to be a
murderous thug even though none of that
happened in the city of tucson where i
worked and it was it was hard man it was
very disheartening because i knew the
men and women who worked with me and
worked around the country
putting your life on the line for other
people i mean this is not a video game
man this is not oh it is you know like
like a pre-recording of something i mean
you you mess up
it's real life this is this is real
at real time and the men and women i
knew their families a lot of people just
great individuals who have a passion for
supporting their communities and to see
them get just ragged on
with false narratives being pushed was
something that was like you know what i
got to write a book and i got to tell
the story and correct some of this stuff
because people aren't getting a fair
evaluation of law enforcement if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell